Speaker 1: All right, I have a clip for you
guys today that I think you're going to really
enjoy now I have to tell you, I have not been
able to get a straight answer as to who the
reporter is.
That asked this bizarre cringy question yesterday
of Jen Psaki during the press briefing.
One person told me it was someone from Newsmax,
but the person from Newsmax has denied that
they were even there yesterday.
So I don't know who this is, but I'm going
to play for you.
Such a cringe question.
This makes Peter Doocy, who regularly asks
absurd questions during the press briefings,
actually seems sort of prepared.
And there's a couple interesting things that
go on here.
We're going to hear a question read that is
literally being read.
You will see the reporter looking down and
reading the question.
And what happens sometimes is when you read
or use a talking point that you don't really
understand.
As soon as there's any question asked about
it, as soon as there's any even remote pushback
about it, it becomes humiliating and embarrassing.
This happened when I was in Los Angeles and
was interviewed by Jesse Lee Peterson.
Jesse Lee Peterson was talking to me about
Obama socialism because of phones.
Oh, so-called Obama phones.
And then he got all confused about what even
the talking point is.
And when you just get a talking point, you're
supposed to use and you don't even really
understand it.
It can end up being a complete and total face
plant, and that's what happens here now.
In this particular case, the topic is inflation
and build back better and whatever.
If you're allergic to cringe, I would skip
the next 90 seconds.
OK, let's take a look at this.
And a lot of you know, 20 percent of this
is Jen Psaki now having some tools for handling
these types of bad faith questions.
Eighty percent of it is the reporter just
not having any idea what's going on?
Check it out.
Speaker 3: OK, go ahead.
Of course, the question on inflation
Speaker 5: Many people believe that government
spending is a big factor in the current inflation
levels.
Speaker 1: By the way, many people believe
is also good like that that becomes a factor
later as well.
Speaker 5: Can you speak to concerns?
The spending plans that come out of build
back better aren't paid for and so could mean
higher deficits and more inflation in
Speaker 3: the future aren't paid for?
Build back better is paid for.
Entirely.
Speaker 1: OK, so you've got to be able to
say, where do you see that it's not paid for
because the whole thing with build back better
was it is paid for.
Now I'll talk more about that in a moment.
You could disagree with how it's paid for.
Or you could say, I don't believe the number,
right?
But you've got to be able to because the whole
thing with build back better was it is paid
for.
Speaker 5: Can you speak to the concerns that
are coming in that who
Speaker 3: are the certainly from now, but
who's saying it's not paid for?
Speaker 1: This pause is maybe one of the
most.
Significant pauses that I've ever seen during
a press briefing, I'm even going to back it
up because the pause is everything here.
Speaker 3: But who's saying it's not paid
for?
Because there have been a range of economists
saying it's entirely paid for now.
Speaker 1: I, Jen Psaki bails her out.
Jen Psaki should have allowed the silence
to go on even longer, but she doesn't.
She bails her out.
Speaker 3: And that has been a priority for
the president.
It has also been concluded by a number of
Nobel laureates and experts from a range of
economic experts on the outside that it will
not contribute to inflation.
So those are the global experts that we would
point to, but there may be others suggesting
something else, but I don't know who those
people are.
Those bills do pass.
It will not raise taxes.
Speaker 1: Now, see, this is it now.
Here's the problem.
This is a completely different question.
No, you pay for it through taxation.
That's so so the it's the reporter doesn't
seem to even understand what's going on.
Is it paid for versus versus?
Do any taxes go up or two different questions?
And it's just a mess.
This person has no business being in the press
briefing room.
Speaker 3: Well, something being entirely
paid for means that part of that is the highest
income Americans.
Highest that companies would be asked to pay
Speaker 1: paid for means there's a cost,
but you raise the money to pay for it
Speaker 3: a bit more.
That has been part of the proposal in part
of reforming the tax system to make it more
fair.
So they're also not expected to contribute
to future inflation.
Speaker 1: But like now, she's just grasping
at straws.
Speaker 3: The build back better bill again,
it's fully paid for.
We would point to Nobel laureates and a range
of global economists who conveyed that it
would not contribute to inflationary pressures.
Go ahead.
Speaker 1: I almost like starting to feel
bad because it's so it's so, so wacky.
You know, the question itself is just as bad
as Peter duces questions.
But Doocy is ready with a comeback and is
ready with a slicker goalposts shift, and
that's where she went wrong.
The silence is just cringeworthy.
And then, she says, so taxes won't go up.
Now let's first talk about build back better,
which seems to be basically dead, although
Joe Biden is going to look at whether he can
do parts of it through executive orders, et
cetera.
There's a Tax Foundation General Equilibrium
Model, which scored to build back better.
There's a Congressional Budget Office model
which scored build back better.
It's very close to revenue neutral based on
slightly different assumptions.
Now, Build Back Better, has tax increases
on the rich and some other different changes
to business taxes and other things which would
offset the spending.
So the concept is very simple.
You do $100 in spending, but you take in an
extra $100.
That's one hundred minus one hundred, right?
So you've got zero there.
That's that's what paid for means in this
context.
There is, you know, I have no interest in
obscuring from you guys that there is disagreement
as to whether things would cost exactly what
is projected 10 years out.
And as to whether the exact amount of revenue
would be raised that the Biden administration
predicts.
There's a real question when you're talking
about spending projected out years and revenue
projected out years, particularly when the
revenue is not, if I recall correctly accounting
for a dynamic tax model, which says, well,
OK, here's how much you would get if you change
the tax and nobody changes their behavior.
But typically, when you change a tax, people
do change their behavior.
You've got to account for that.
I'm more than glad to admit that to you guys,
because that's the case with any bill.
You could say, Hey, you know what?
This actually could be a little bit.
This could actually raise the deficit a little
bit because this thing's going to cost a little
bit more.
And this thing is going to raise a little
bit less money.
That's perfectly fair.
And that would be the case with any one of
these bills.
The problem is the reporter doesn't even know
what's going on.
She seems dazed.
She doesn't seem to understand even the difference
between paying for something and what it means
to raise taxes or what is what is revenue
neutral mean.
She just has absolutely no business being
there and Jen Psaki handling it well, but
it's not a difficult one to handle because
she's completely clueless.